the biden administration held its first
white house press briefing just hours
after president joe biden was sworn in
press secretary jen saki promises daily
briefings
that's a stark contrast to the trump
administration which at one point went
more than 300 days without one
saki vowed to be truthful and
transparent set that tone early on and
she joins us now from the white house
north lawn jan good morning to you
hopefully good morning tony
hopefully first of many appearances we
have a lot to get to but the thing that
hangs over all of it is that subject of
truthfulness and honesty
you say we both share the goal of
providing accurate information to the
american people
but the reality is there's a portion of
the public a meaningful portion
that doesn't believe that and as mitch
mcconnell said they've been fed lies
so how do you begin today to rebuild
trust in our institutions
well tony the best antidote to false
information
is the truth and honesty and data and
transparency and
that is what we will venture to try to
deliver on each day not just in the
white house briefing uh from the
briefing room
but also from this white house so we'll
see if we can do it but
that certainly is our objective and i
will say that the president himself is
very committed to rebuilding trust you
know
like no time probably in modern american
history this is part of all of our
objectives here
part of my job as the press secretary
part of the jobs of the policy teams
part of his job part of the vice
president's jobs
because the institutions around the
country have been the trust in them has
been so
frayed trust in media and trusted in
government and it's going to take some
time though it's not going to happen
overnight it is going to take some time
i wish telling the truth were all that
we're going to take to rebuild that
trust but we'll leave it there for now
let's talk about the
covid plan that was announced overnight
we're going to see 10 executive actions
today we hear
uh it's been described by some as
maddeningly maddeningly
obvious and at the same time joe biden
is saying he's going to manage the hell
out of it what detail can you put on
what to expect
in rolling out a vaccine and providing
enough vaccine for 100 million americans
to get a dose
in a hundred days well he's set a very
ambitious goal
which you touched on which is 100
million shots in the arms of americans
in the first hundred days
and there are some very clear uh steps
that he's outlined to do exactly that
and he'll talk more about it today
one of them is invoking the defense
production act because a big
issue here which may seem obvious to
many is supply we need more supply of
not just the vaccines
but the materials to get them in the
arms of americans to effectively get
this done
uh and we'll also have dr fausch come to
the briefing room today to talk more
specifically about it as well so supply
is a big part of this the defense
production act would allow the federal
government to in essence take over
factories and produce what is needed
are all the ingredients though that need
to be sourced from around the world
available to actually make more of the
vaccines to speed them into people's
bodies
well as you know there are a number of
vaccines that have been approved by the
fda and we certainly abide by their
guidelines here in the united states
uh there are more that are under
consideration as you also know
um but you know one of the the big
challenges that we've seen is the
ability
to get the vaccines the the the medicine
the vaccines into the arms of americans
right so having the materials needed to
get them out to communities um and that
has a range of different meanings but
it's really the physical
manufactured supplies also that are
important not just the vaccine itself
it's also about getting to communities
that don't have access to health care in
an easy way making this accessible
making it easy for people to
go get the vaccine and know when they
can get it i'm sure you've had calls
from members of your family as have i
about when they can sign up when it's
their turn and we need to do a better
job of publicly communicating about that
yeah well we've got one grandmother in
israel in my family that's got a vaccine
and another grandmother here in the
united states that has not and it's
definitely
stark contrast let's talk about the 1.9
trillion dollar covert relief package
there are republicans who bought that
even a less than one trillion dollar
relief package this is twice as large
joe biden knows the senate kamala harris
knows the senate
what conversations with republicans have
begun to get this thing through
well they already began those
conversations even before they both took
the oaths of office yesterday and those
will continue
and and continue with speed in the days
ahead now that they are
having their full state first full day
in office today tony but
you know that the package was not
designed to make it big and eye
shopping or eye shocking with the size
it was designed because those are the
key components
needed to address the crises we're
facing money for vaccine distributions
allowing americans to apply for
unemployment insurance for a longer
period of time
money to reopen schools what are you
exactly going to cut from that bucket
it's all essential and it's all
important in the moment we're facing
in this country jen i want to talk about
this moment unity
is on the table it was a big part of the
inaugural address but then on day one
just hours after that speech 17
different executive actions rolled back
significant parts of president trump's
legacy
how do you how do you square the uh push
for unity
with an aggressive push to undo what 75
million americans
wanted to continue to be done they
supported president trump
well i'll say revoking the muslim ban
xenophobic uh action that was taken by
the prime m for the prior administration
i think that is helping to unify the
country uh in in
indicating to the american public that
we are going to put climate change
address the climate crisis
that is impacting communities democrats
republicans blue states red
states and helping people be healthy
that's going to help the
unify the public you know these are
issues he took because he felt that
immediate action was warranted
that we needed to take immediate steps
in order to bring relief to the public
but he's also going to work with
congress he's already announced a number
of packages
on immigration uncovered relief to do
exactly that but
these were steps that he felt were so
imperative that he needed to take them
on day one and he'll take more today on
kovid
hey jin saki it's gayle king here hi
michael beschloss the presidential
historian tweeted last night
first non-weird press secretary in four
years
i'm wondering how long you intend to
keep that going non-weird well that's
quite a description
i think i can achieve more than that
gail i hope and non-weird um
you know we're going to be briefing i'm
going to be doing the briefing monday
through friday five days a week we'll
bring some special guests we're bringing
dr fauci today we want to introduce the
diverse faces and voices and the policy
experts who are going to be leading all
these efforts
across government so we'll do that on a
number of days
but you know my objective is to help
rebuild trust with the public
um and and i go into it every day with
an understanding that there's going to
be healthy debates in there that's the
job of the media
and my job is to uh kind of represent
the views of the president but
that's what people should expect to see
and that debate's healthy it's part of
our democracy
truth and transparency is a good start
and i look forward to it yeah
first appearance of many we hope jen
saki thank you very much